Today
my husband asked for beef tacos and I didn't want to let him down,
so I slaughtered our cow and picked the corn myself.
As a tried wife, my family's health is my utmost priority.
This means that after the cow has been slaughtered,
we are sure to save its offline
as the organs are actually the most nutrient dense part of the animal.
While my husband won't be looking forward to this dinner,
I am making our family kidney stew this evening
using one kidney from Harry
as we need our daily dose of B vitamins, iron,
copper,  Colleen  and vitamin a.
I grew up with stories from my mom
telling me and my siblings
that she was obsessed with her aunt's kidney stew,
so I figured it would be just as easy to replicate
even though I didn't have her family recipe.
So after a two day soak in raw milk,
I cooked the kidney pieces with lots of onion,
garlic, spices,
veggies, broth,
flour to thicken, and many hours of simmering on the stove top.
I prepared some wild rice that have been soaked in advance.
It was time for dinner.
I plated each dish with a bed of rice stew and garnished with parsley
as my children sat around me for the moment of truth.
I was so proud by what I had created.
Is it not what you expected?
Definitely not what I expected.
It's not yummy. It's yummy,
but not what I expected.